I'm sorry to say that I'm watching Chainsaw Man,
but if
everyone is watching it, I
can tell that there is no foreshadowing like Dragon Ball.
No, no, no, the main character's name is Denji
Seriously,
there are too many posts about Kidney Man,
and even if the original story is good, the
CG is unforgivable
.
If you really have time to make this Chainsaw Man,
I'd like you to use it in the final season of Giants How long will you keep me waiting
?
So I was streaming my reaction when I saw the battle
between Gala and Kimimaro.
I don't talk about the spy family
I ca
n't.
It's not in good taste, no, it's too late
Even if you practice anime lists, it wo
n't change anything Bye-bye You're watching Butterfly
because you want to cry